you and I are about to play a quick
little game true truths and a lie I
originally wanted to play Regina George
in Mean Girls Raven Simone and I were
roommates the dance number in Mean Girls
was supposed to be here comes Santa
Claus instead of Jingle Bell Rock and
the LIE is
Here Comes Santa Claus was supposed to
be the song instead of Jingle Bell Rock
Jingle Bell Rock was always supposed to
be the song in the dance number at the
talent show in Mean Girls and it was a
great time we were all a little nervous
to do it we had to learn the dance so
quickly but we had a lot of fun with it
don't know how to do the whole number no
it's like the other thing with The
Parent Trap handshake I'd have to watch
it and then I could do it I originally
wanted to play Regina George because it
was it was like the prettier cooler girl
role to play and I hadn't been able to
play something like that and it just
wasn't happening our director Mark
Waters was like no you're playing Katie
I mean I tend to always gravitate
towards the underdog and and the
character with the most Arc in movies so
that's that's kind of where my heart
lies